mais au Championnat d'Auvergne jeune
j'ai 11 ans j'apprends ton anniversaire
qui on est à 16 qui fait deux têtes de
plus que moi dans environ 1800 kg tous
les deux et au monde se serrer la main
pour souhaiter une bonne partie à la
place il me lâche au calme un petit
avec un regard du genre je retire ma
main tant bien que mal parce qu'il
essaie de la broyer au passage je joue
E4 il fait C6 c'est une karaoké on
développe nos pièces tout est normal
j'avance mon pion il recule et la maman
critique je vais faire un sacrifice
thématique E6 avec l'idée il reprend et
je crée des grosses faiblesses sur les
cases blanches autour de son roi tout en
bloquant son fou et créant des pions
doublés j'enchaîne par fou des trois
pour activer mon flou blanc et là je
prie pour qu'il ne voit pas ma menace
très sûr de lui me balance E5 avec idée
je vais bloquer ton fou j'ai un pion de
plus en gros je vais te défoncer sauf
que là je saute de ma chaise je joue
dans ma chambre avec un gros sourire et
je vois son visage se décomposer pour la
forme il joue G6 bien sûr sacrifier
madame j'aurais aussi pu prendre du Fou
et il abandonne puisque si il reprend
c'est un maths allez tout faire avec mon
simple fou un petit peu humiliant